[Música]
chile va a las urnas para elegir a las
50 personas que redactarán un nuevo
borrador de la Constitución empieza así
el segundo intento para reformar la
Carta Magna heredada de la época de
Augusto pinochet tras el rechazo de la
población a la primera propuesta en
septiembre de 2022
la liga árabe readmite a Siria en la
organización los Países Árabes abren la
vía diplomática con Damasco que fue
expulsado de la alianza en 2011 en
respuesta a la represión de lassad
contra el pueblo sirio
en Turquía a una semana de las
elecciones el presidente
erdogan se dio un baño de masas en
Estambul un acto de campaña para unos
comicios que se presentan como los más
reñidos de los últimos años Tenemos
reporte desde Estambul
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de France 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
masgueu y es para mí un gusto
acompañarles abrimos esta edición
informativa en Chile porque hoy el país
va a las urnas para elegir a los
miembros del Consejo constitucional las
50 personas que se han elegidas deberán
redactar una segunda propuesta de
Constitución esto luego de que en
septiembre de 2022 los ciudadanos
rechazarán un primer borrador en un
referendo en su punto de votación el
presidente chileno Gabriel borich
expresó la importancia de continuar con
el proceso Constituyente que nació del
estallido social de 2019 y la voluntad
mayoritaria en el país de cambiar la
Carta Magna heredada de la dictadura de
pinochet la elección de los nuevos
consejeros constitucionales
Configura un avance para el país en
donde hemos sido capaces de ponernos de
acuerdo en darle continuidad a un
proceso que no ha sido fácil pero
cuyo sentido nace desde las necesidades
más profundas de nuestro pueblo
conseguir una nueva constitución que nos
una que signifique progreso y que
identifique a la mayoría de los chilenos
para actualizar nuestras normas
fundamentales y precisamente nuestra
corresponsal en Santiago Patricia Luna
nos cuenta la diferencia entre la
composición de este nuevo consejo
constitucional y la asamblea
Constituyente que redactó el texto
anterior
pues serían procesos diametralmente
Opuestos en muchos sentidos Este es un
proceso mucho más institucional diseñado
por el congreso que ya eligió un comité
de expertos en la mitad de 24 miembros
paritarios la mitad el senado la mitad
el congreso que ya está redactando un
anteproyecto que tiene 12 puntos que
tienen que seguirse y sobre el que se
elaborará un texto que será entregado a
este consejo constitucional formado por
50 personas frente a las 155 de la
convención de la convención
constitucional anterior en la que había
una gran representación dos tercios de
candidatos independientes Este es un
nuevo proceso mucho más
canalizado por las instituciones y los
partidos políticos en Chile López
explica también una parte de la
desafección de la ciudadanía vamos ahora
a Estados Unidos porque este sábado
Texas fue escenario de un nuevo tiroteo
ayer a las tres y media de la tarde hora
local un hombre armado irrumpió en un
centro comercial de la localidad de
Allen al norte de Dallas y mató a ocho
personas e hirió al menos a otras 7
minutos después Un policía que se
encontraba en la zona también mató al
atacante
Estados Unidos nuevamente enlutado por
otro acto de violencia Armada un hombre
abrió fuego este 6 de mayo en un centro
comercial en un suburbio cercano a
Dallas en Texas las autoridades
informaron que atendieron inmediatamente
al Llamado de emergencia y que el
atacante murió a manos de la policía
uno de nuestros oficiales se respondió a
una llamada en el centro comercial
escuchó disparos entró en la escena se
enfrentó al sospechoso y lo contuvo
también llamó a las ambulancias las
agencias nos ayudaron a trabajar en la
escena
he hablado con el gobernador quien ha
prometido el apoyo total del estado
los primeros informes aseguran que el
tirador llegó en automóvil al centro
comercial y apenas se bajó ingresó a una
tienda para posteriormente empezar a
disparar indiscriminadamente contra las
personas que se encontraban en el
establecimiento decenas de personas
fueron evacuadas
Mi hija acaba de enviarme un mensaje de
texto y dijo papá te amo y hay una
situación activa ya sabes volátil hay un
tiroteo solo oren por mí así que
corrimos corrimos ahí
las autoridades informaron que se abrió
una investigación para esclarecer los
hechos en lo que va del 2023 Estados
Unidos ha sufrido al menos 198 tiroteos
masivos los cuales bienvenidos como
aquellos en los que mueren cuatro o más
personas sin incluir al perpetrador
según la organización gangliolence
vamos ahora a Egipto Por qué reunidos en
la capital El Cairo los delegados de la
liga árabe decidieron reamitir a Siria
en la organización el país fue expulsado
en 2011 como respuesta a la violenta
represión de lassad contra las protestas
ciudadanas una situación que recordemos
acabó desencadenando una guerra civil
entre varios actores como el estado
islámico por su parte Estados Unidos
dice que Siria no merece readmisión en
la liga árabe
tras 12 años de suspensión Siria es
remitida en la liga árabe la decisión
fue tomada a Puerta cerrada por los
ministros de exteriores de los países
miembros del organismo el reingreso vino
acompañado entre otros aspectos de un
llamado de atención a los actores del
conflicto interno sirio para resolver la
crisis
es necesario defender el concepto de una
patria integral y segura y el
cumplimiento de cada uno de los
componentes del gobierno sirio las
fuerzas nacionales la comunidad
internacional los países interesados con
sus obligaciones hacia los demás para
que Siria vuelva a los sirios unificada
estable e independiente
la resolución no contó con un respaldo
unánime varios estados entre ellos Qatar
se oponen a una reapertura con Damasco
sin tener sobre la mesa una solución
política en este sentido se creará una
comisión conformada por varias naciones
y el secretario general de la liga para
buscar soluciones a la guerra civil
el regreso de Siria es el comienzo de un
movimiento no el final la dirección de
la resolución de la crisis llevará
tiempo para que se apliquen los
procedimientos será gradual la tarea de
esta comisión es hacer seguimientos de
estos procedimientos el gobierno sirio
reaccionó con un pedido el desarrollo de
un enfoque efectivo basado sobre el
respeto mutuo entre los estados miembros
de la liga árabe Siria fue expulsada en
el año 2011 tras la represión de las
fuerzas del orden contra las protestas
que pedían un cambio de gobierno
los manifestantes reclamaban El Fin Del
mandato de la familia al azar tras 40
años en el poder
en otras noticias mientras continúan los
combates en Sudán en la ciudad de lleda
en Arabia Saudita y bajo el auspicio de
representantes de Washington y de read
emisarios del ejército regular su danés
y de los paramilitares de las fuerzas de
apoyo rápido se reúnen en el que es el
primer esfuerzo diplomático real para
intentar poner fin al conflicto sin
embargo ambas partes han dejado Claro
que los diálogos no buscan la paz si no
establecer vías humanitarias para
aliviar la crisis desatada por los
enfrentamientos que empezaron el 15 de
abril
y en Turquía a una semana de las
elecciones el presidente
erdogan protagonizó un baño de masas en
un acto de campaña en Estambul Y es que
estos comicios marcados por una difícil
situación económica en el país y el
recuerdo del mortal terremoto de febrero
representan el mayor desafío para el
actual mandatario que lleva dos décadas
en el poder nuestro corresponsal alberna
Ya estuvo ahí en mínimos de popularidad
del presidente resienta y verdogan se
presenta a unas elecciones con sabor a
plebiscito todas estas personas que
están aquí para ellos estos comicios
significan el todo o la nada porque a
pesar de la gran crisis económica que
atraviesa el país o la gestión que hizo
el Gobierno con el terremoto siguen
apoyando a su líder y no conciben una
Turquía sin él también le apoyan los
simpatizantes del partido
ultranacionalista el mhp tal como
ocurrió en la anterior legislatura a
sabiendas que las encuestas indican que
la coalición opositora le saca una
ligera ventaja el presidente ha hecho
gala durante esta campaña de las
múltiples construcciones que se han
hecho en materia de infraestructura de
los proyectos energéticos que ya están
en marcha o de los hallazgos de gas y
petróleo en los últimos meses según el
gobierno dará más Independencia a estos
hallazgos al país en un momento en que
las facturas ya estaban empezando a
ahogar a los habitantes del país
euroasiático por lo tanto y a una sola
semana de acudir a las urnas Estas son
las miles de personas que entre ellas
van a votar al presidente ahí perdoban
cambiamos de tema porque este domingo
Rusia acusó a Ucrania de lanzar un nuevo
ataque con drones sobre la Península de
crimea una acusación sobre la que kiev
guarda silencio hasta el momento
mientras a esta hora se desconocen los
daños causados por las explosiones por
otro lado el líder del grupo Wagner que
el viernes amenazó con retirar a sus
tropas de badmud no le enviaba más
munición aseguró ahora que esta noche el
kremlin le prometió enviar todo el
armamento necesario para continuar con
la operación en la ciudad escenario de
la batalla más larga de esta guerra
y en otras noticias de la guerra
alegando la intensificación de los
bombardeos ucranianos las fuerzas rusas
anunciaron un plan para evacuar a los
civiles de 18 municipios de la zona que
controlan en la región de saporilla esto
incluyendo la localidad de enero rodar
un la cercanía de la planta nuclear más
grande de Europa los hechos han generado
preocupación en el organismo
internacional para la energía atómica
la central nuclear de saporilla está
cada vez más en riesgo por la guerra
Esta es la alerta del director general
de la agencia internacional de energía
atómica en un comunicado Rafael grossi
advirtió sobre el riesgo de un grave
accidente nuclear la situación general
en el área cercana a la planta de
energía nuclear de saporillas está
volviendo cada vez más impredecible y
potencialmente peligrosa estoy
extremadamente preocupado por los
riesgos muy reales de seguridad y
protección nuclear para la planta
debemos actuar de la mano para evitar la
amenaza de un accidente nuclear Severo y
sus consecuencias para las personas y el
medio ambiente una situación inestable
provocada por las operaciones militares
en torno a esta planta la más grande de
Europa y que las fuerzas rusas tomaron
desde marzo de 2022 al inicio de la
guerra y aunque los seis reactores están
apagados el riesgo de un desastre en
caso de bombardeo sigue siendo
importante según informó la agencia
expertos del Hoya presentes en el lugar
permanentemente dicen que escucharon
bombardeos el pasado 5 de Mayo según
analistas la contraofensiva anunciada
recientemente por Ucrania Podría tener
lugar en la región de saporilla
controlada en un 80% por las fuerzas
rusas ante la intensificación de los
bombardeos El oficial regional instalado
por moscúa aseguró que inició las
evacuaciones de civiles de 18
localidades en particular de nergodar
para enviarlos a ciudades aledañas
70.000 personas deberían ser evacuadas
de esta forma pero por ahora los
empleados de la planta no están
incluidos según las autoridades rusas y
el Primer Ministro japonés fumió se
encuentra en Corea del Sur en una visita
sin precedentes en la última década allí
fue recibido por el presidente
surcoreano y un sukil con el que abordó
temas como la cooperación económica y la
seguridad regional esto en medio de las
tensiones con Corea del Norte
dos enemigos históricos unidos por un
factor común Corea del Norte 12 años
después de la última visita de un
premiere japonés a Corea del Sur El
actual jefe de gobierno fumichida fue
recibido en seúl por el presidente
Johnson los dos líderes identificaron al
régimen de Kim jong-un como una amenaza
ambos países están expuestos a las
amenazas nucleares norcoreanas la
cooperación en materia de seguridad es
ahora más importante que nunca en este
sentido subrayaron la alianza con
Estados Unidos como estratégica para
hacer frente a las provocaciones
de acuerdo con la alianza japonesa
Estados Unidos la alianza Corea del Sur
Estados Unidos y la cooperación de
seguridad entre Japón Corea del Sur y
Estados Unidos coincidimos en la
importancia de fortalecer la disuasión y
la capacidad de hacer frente
en medio de la visita se abordaron entre
otros temas el fortalecimiento de la
cooperación en el área de los
semiconductores el vertido regulado de
las aguas residuales de la planta
nuclear de fukushima y la expansión de
las rutas aéreas a nivel prepandémico
Esta visita generó protestas por parte
de los manifestantes quienes exigen
incluir en la agenda de la Cumbre un
tema histórico la ocupación por parte de
Japón de la Península entre 1910 y 1945
Corea del Sur estuvo bajo El dominio
colonial japonés más de 780000
surcoreanos fueron movilizados para
trabajos forzados o como esclavos
sexuales del ejército en 2015 Japón
presentó una disculpa oficial
comprometiéndose a pagar más de siete
millones de dólares a un fondo de ayuda
a las víctimas de la guerra pero el
acuerdo Fue cancelado más tarde por
Corea del Sur con este encuentro sukyol
siguen dispuestos a enterrar el hacha de
guerra entre sus naciones
gracias por su atención sigan con
nosotros
[Música]